sean um so what were you seeing up there
by the capitol building
so i was not inside the capitol building
but i was seeing some tear gas being
shot and people trying to break in and
people coming out and i talked to a lot
of people who said that they got inside
the building
and then the cops cleared them out after
they got inside and they got pepper
sprayed and
you know thrown out and people are
trying to get in again and there's just
a lot of back and forth between riot
police and protesters
and are there still people inside there
now that you can see uh i
i was not inside i just know what i
heard from the people coming out with
the tear
you know the tear gas all over their
face so
and do you feel that this sort of scene
is helpful
what point are they trying to make here
i think
i think a lot of i think a lot of people
are
trying to intimidate the congress but
they're they're very angry because
congress is very corrupt and they're
trying to scare them in a lot of ways
and to
complying because it's like a
show of power